all right Justin thanks for talking
about Monster Hunter overwatch thanks
for coming Magnus onto the lobby
yeah giving us a resounding successful
hosting job you're a professional host
through and through thank you he's so
much more than that are you gonna talk
about what your next adventure is or is
it is that hush-hush for now yeah I
think I could talk about it we're gonna
transition into the next segment here
and talk about GameSpot over the past
nine or so years and then talk about
GameSpot into the future with both
myself and Ty route taking off Mary
kitchens gonna come on in chat but you
and I will talk later about more stuff
like that mister hey Walt thank you
no thank you fare thee well mr. Brown
stick around cuz you've been here for
how many of my guess nine years all
right yes Peter Brown started at
GameSpot mm-hmm
you have been here for five and a half
years oh it's pretty close almost five
almost five I started in October
November of 11 Mary what are you doing
on the set come here Justin his sneaking
about Oh God he left he left his
computer that's how you sneak in what's
that Alpha Protocol I'll remember that
game yep this is the no one knows I'm
here hey guys I'm here I'll bet you
didn't see me approach alpha protocol hi
Mary Kish hi Chris waters ah welcome to
the lobby we're here to talk about
something that is very near and dear to
all our hearts this is gonna be a Dan
you are hosted segment talking about you
know me and my time at GameSpot and all
the changes but uh Danny's horribly ill
and so we're gonna we're gonna do it
ourselves because you guys have been
here for quite some time as well I mean
it's no nine and a half years the way
it's going we're seniors now yep
yeah you said you've been here for five
years Mary I've been here for three yeah
and so you guys have seen you sort of
come in at different eras of my GameSpot
career when you came on Peter I was a
reviewer you were doing yeah a lot of
reviews a lot of previews which you
offered a lot of guidance you yeah yes
sir all right let's talk let's go
through the phases of waters career
because great you didn't start where
many people might think you started did
you you're a janitor right yes no I came
on I mostly just hanging around the
loading dock and you know picking up
litter occasionally just scout no I
started in 2007 as a data producer which
now what does that mean that's Marco
Martinez and gacha cool letting him do
this do similar versions of this job now
but it's basically like keeping the site
up-to-date with screenshots and release
dates and stats on games and posting
data and creating new game spaces for
games like it's why when you go to
GameSpot you can get information about
games and it's because someone in the
data produced production team has put
the basics in there and created that
skeleton so that job was like I mean my
qualifications for that job were like an
internship I had a GamesRadar where I
did kind of that and also wrote new
stories but it was a lot about
maintaining you know I'm keeping my eye
on a large diversity of games but when I
came on that was wild Jeff Gerstmann was
still AIC and alex navaro was it the
head of reviews and I told him right
away look I want to write reviews I want
to I want to be a writer for the site
that's why I came here that's what I
want to do and they're like all right
cool and you know then I had a manager
then who was who would let me like trial
by fire there's a new Sonic game yeah
was because this was the year that we
came out was pool party for the week
pool Wow
yeah what kind of pool are we talking
like billiards are we talking about
billiards with in a pool no there was no
actual pool though it's a swimming it
was you know line them up and hit the
cue balls into the other balls make the
balls go in the hole
that's my least favorite pool party
again I think it was pretty I think I
was like a five or a six
so it was like look this works fine it's
real bare-bones but that was my I think
that was my first GameSpot byline and
this was like literally something that
Alex and Varro I don't know he like
bought it in a bargain bin at Target
right it was part of that we like shovel
oh my god they found it there it is
five technical tuning allows for nasty
trick show selection of pool game's
technical suiting allows for easy
misfires and a little parallelism before
you guys I'd like to know large useless
image obscure the table oh that's right
oh it's broken just had this huge leak
you're trying to aim and there's like a
big thing in the way but the logo for
the game in the middle the screen pool
party and then sound is maddening that's
never a good sign though oh wow
eloquently said though the sound is
maddening oh God
so frustrating but yeah so that like you
know then there was a pretty sizable
exodus on the GameSpot editorial side
and Thanksgiving a giant accident yes a
December that led to the creation of
Giant Bomb a year later but that opened
up a place on the review scene and so I
went over there and began what that was
like my second job of four by the way at
GameSpot and this is one I really value
this time because as Peters sort of
alluded to this was a time of like
professional development in that the
writing was like evils like The Crucible
on which you were proven Peter the QA
process oh man we still peer-review
everything with a very keen eye on
grammar and all those things but also
like style and voice and making sure
arguments are very solid and I had done
a lot of like tech writing before coming
the game spa but I never really reviewed
games on the scale the way we do now or
then and I'll remember I'll never forget
my first few reviews sending those
around and getting a feedback I was like
I am either the worst writer in the
world or these people have no respect
for me both both it was the exact ratio
what it boiled down to is that I had a
lot I had a lot of ground to cover in
terms of becoming a good writer that you
know could stand up to people like
yourself and Carolyn Petitte and Tom
McShea
and it it was really hard and but you
guys definitely got me in the right
mindset and I'm just I'm still learning
I'm still figuring stuff out but you
guys were critical to my development
here dude it was sure it was every day
like not just every review you you I
would write but every review everyone
else would write they would send around
and you just go you would just go
through it and be like okay you know not
just we had a copy editor so grammar was
mostly taken care true yeah but um you'd
be like oh hey here's where you could
have made your point better hey I'm not
sure I'm not I don't quite get it
hey this this doesn't seem as big a
deals as you think it seems like it
should be a way bigger deal right
why did you barely talk about this why
are you talking about this so much like
literally from all angles yeah yeah I
remember it it was a process that we
tried to like soft-pedal a little bit
for newcomers but anyway you go about it
it's it was vicious it wasn't vicious it
was intense it was not mean-spirited no
one was he punches
thorough yeah yeah it was Kevyn Orr's
got a quite a haymaker
yeah short arms though but this is one
of the things I was thinking about it
and over the years at GameSpot I've
gotten the question a lot you know like
how do I get to get your job how do I
get to work at a GameSpot I'm sure you
guys have gotten that question dozens of
times ourselves one of the things that
ice the first thing I say is whatever
you want to do just start doing it yeah
start doing it and I'm not saying you're
starting and just writing for GameSpot
you are you want to write reviews start
writing or even write your reviews and
you know it's most like when you start
it's gonna be for yourself it's gonna be
it's gonna be I like doing this it's
gonna be oh this one was better than the
last one it's gonna be how did I take on
this game versus this game versus this
game but the second part is to get
yourself into a community where people
will give you feedback
because that was what like made me at
you know and in terms of my writer and a
critical thinker that was like intense
professional development and it's so
valuable to get that kind of feedback
yeah even if it's not always the easiest
process dude I went to art school for
four years I dealt with a lot of
critical feedback and that couldn't even
prepare me for this sort of dissections
that were happening reviews are very
personal too so you kind of put your
heart in your review just so to have
someone critique it can almost feel like
a little bit of a personal attack so I
think it can be you kind of have to
build up quite a shell to work here at
any review site not just from your peers
people who you respect but from the
mountains and mountains of mean comments
that you will receive on something that
you worked really hard on and I really
you put put your best into I think it's
I don't think it's easy to be a reviewer
it's definitely not easy and yet the
comments the you know ten comments about
a good review hey nice work and the one
that's like wow this reviewer is really
terrible and can't make a good argument
and that what that score doesn't make
sense that's the one that sticks with
you it keeps you up at night
well until you learn to process that and
I think you know people describe it as a
shell but for me like it it's like it's
an inner strength it's an inner
confidence it's like hey this stuff is
just gonna like like you know if it
sticks in me it's like a little sting
it's gonna go away but I know because I
have dedicated myself to this work that
I'm doing good work I know because I'm
engaged with people who are engaged with
me about this work and giving me good
feedback that's the opinion that matters
I know that I'm moving forward and
growing so yeah definitely developing
that strength of you know not strength
to the point where you're like I'm right
all they are not gonna be and we need
people to tell you that and needs to be
able to tell that to yourself so yeah
that was a really great time for me at
GameSpot was that review squad yeah and
I loved being a part of that team with
you I mean I looked up to you and you
know I still do but I just remember like
the caliber of your writing the caliber
of your critiques were so high that it
was just like I want to imprint like you
were one of the people I wanted to
impress the most it
cuz at least in terms of how how I
improved over time because I thought man
this guy knows like like everyone else
did too but you had your own angle and I
was like that's I want to I want to
please that that perspective
thank you Peter that means that means a
lot to me a personal anecdote out there
like I I always liked you from day one
when I liked you more yeah when I I knew
I really liked you when you and I got in
a pretty cool argument in Germany one
year that involves a lot of yelling and
fist pounding on the table and it was
over something pretty just meaningless
but like we were [ __ ] going at it
pardon language and you know the next
day it was like a funny story and I was
just worried that like I had offended
you but I was glad that I still liked to
you after that yeah I don't like this
guy okay yeah there's good reasons there
even though we have you like dude we
were we were oh it was great like at
this bar in Germany like like briskly
very briskly back and forth and like you
don't even dude you're not even making
set like literally like not like I
remember the conversation kind of like
ad hominem attacks but to the point of
like listen your whole argument your
whole perspective is invalid like I was
we were both entrench but like and like
we weren't the only ones in the bar all
our other co-workers were around like
hey we're gonna go over here yeah you
know it's look at this candle the mat
the wax is melted and it looks like a
duck penis no it was really people like
we were having this heated argument I
don't think it had like a real exchange
up until that point it always been like
sort of like passing just like oh yeah
hey what's up you know like that kind of
thing yeah we got to know each other you
know it's funny is I mean I wouldn't say
it was a turning point for me Mary but
there was another time in public where I
got in a big argument with Mary over
stuff we were yelling about make fists
up it's able over something oh yeah
let's do it
Peter and I had a
really a really bad argument where we
actually were fighting about whether or
not you could eat a bagel with cream
cheese upside-down - navin not get in
your beard and mustache turn the cream
cheese facing down oh here we go
if you flipped it upside down that that
would prevent cream cheese issues
Peter was adamant that it wouldn't he's
bearded I was pretty sure I was right at
the time yeah so anyway we got really
and then I think like like yelling and
then I don't know like a couple months
later he was like fighting about and
then we we remembered what it was and I
was like oh yeah you're totally right
and he was just like that's how I bond
with people if I get an argument that's
our way well I mean that's it that seems
like it's it's a bit of a theme here is
like look if you are you know engaged
with something you know ours was was
game related was more it was about VR
and sort of a user experience of VR and
how you could judge the quality of VR
and whatnot you know whether it's sort
of career related or not you can have
these intense interactions with people
and come out stronger than ever before
especially you here
a testament to being responsible and
mature and not upsetting people
you hear that narrative that dominant
narrative here folks no matter what else
you heard even though you had quite the
run at reviews you also did a lot more
besides that didn't you Chris what else
did you transition my transition well
this is one of the things about GameSpot
that like I am so grateful for having
worked here is like here I am on video
talking into a camera this is not
something I ever envisioned I would do
this is not something I ever thought I
wanted to do or would even be good at
doing necessarily but because I was a
GameSpot because I did video reviews and
then was on on the spot and other shows
I got opportunity hosting III stuff I
got the opportunity to do it and I
really liked it it's it's like really
fun and it became this avenue of
professional development that yeah
that I carried and did
years of video just mostly video
production in terms of not production in
terms of like I can edit video that's
what you were there during that period
where we had edit our own videos they
tried to get me some edit video a few
times a month and I'm not saying that
that's not a good idea
listen if you have any inclination of
working in the video field I highly
recommend you pick up some video editing
skills prove it ah no I'm already here
I'm already good but yeah like like
working on video scripts and we'll talk
about this a little bit when we get Thai
root in here is gamespot over you know
the past many years has shifted well you
know to put a lot more resources into
video because that's an incredible way
for people to engage with you know video
games and also just a dynamic way for us
to engage our hosts are our audience and
y'all like to watch some videos videos
are popular on internet mm-hmm also a
live video was starting to get popular
and GameSpot was at the forefront of
that we had live shows run by like a
dynamic team from like Ryan McDonald and
Jim Genma Jair and Dan mejor ik who
works tirelessly to kind of make
everything work and on the spot was kind
of like our our show that was what made
people think of GameSpot was on the spot
so like ship video product I mean this
is yeah this is like the fourth or fifth
incarnation of that show and you know by
all means yeah this is on the spot in
fact we went through a lot of iterations
of calling at that but we decided to
kind of move forward in a different
direction in fact in the day which was
already a few years ago now because this
shows been going off for a little bit
yeah but there was a period where I was
on the show a lot and then I wasn't on
the show that was a period so I'm moving
into my like so the video video host and
producer then like the might the fourth
and final period of my employment at
GameSpot was as a producer in the are
sponsored content initiatives so if you
guys watched like inside Fire Emblem
fates and lego dimensions and Holiday
Gift Guide and a lot of these things
these videos we worked on over the years
that are sponsored by clients we don't
have our editorial staff go on
because our editorial staff does not get
sponsored we don't take we are not
influenced by the money that is spent on
advertising we don't get the shakes
scores don't get checks Peter those like
coming out of my own personal agenda
Fonda I've been seating in it and it
isolated you to some degree where now
that you were a part of sponsored
content you were actually no longer
allowed to do anything editorial from
reviews to opinionated pieces to our
editorial show which is the lobby so
unfortunately although that decision
made you so monumental and other things
that helped GameSpot incredibly they
were like kind of more behind the scenes
in many ways and a lot of people miss
you a lot people ways were wondering
where's that guy at that we like yeah
what's he what's he doing what was the
last review you wrote I believe it was
Halo four pull it up
or it was did I do like some small
irritant is that after Halo four
irritant was like this small indie
platformer thing that was not quite
finished that I reviewed
I remember the halo yeah it was that was
probably the last big one but so the
reason that I sort of disappeared and I
I guess I think I talked about this a
little bit in various formats but that
was me like trying to try something new
you know like reaching a point where
I've been at GameSpot for seven years
and realizing like hey I need a new
growth opportunity I need to take on new
challenges like there's a lot that goes
on in this company that I don't know a
ton about and so let me try to let me
try to do that let me try to find a new
kind of area to learn about and I really
did and working with clients and working
with sales and do and like working that
whole pipeline which is like almost
totally unseen by the audience you know
that you only see the final products and
that's only on the ones that get sold
like now I come up with ideas come up
with a dozen ideas and one of them gets
made just because that's the nature of
pitching things to clients you're the
least
favorite idea not always
ya know I we made some cool stuff during
that project but I also realized that I
came to miss being on camera a bunch and
miss hosting video and miss talking with
you all and miss being front of y'all
and that was something that you know
helped motivate me to start looking
around for a new gig which is why I am
leaving GameSpot because I have a new
job that I'm starting in about a week
and a half
can you tell us more about that job
Chris wires sure marry Kish that job is
I'm going to be you know I've been
curious for many years about the other
side we're a media company what's on the
other side of that publishing company's
game people that make games I have
really no skills germane to making games
but I am gonna be going to work for a
publisher Ubisoft and I'm gonna be
working there on a team that does their
content for their YouTube channel and UB
blog and really growing that video
presence there we have a beloved
co-worker of ours and friend of GameSpot
Andy Bauman went over there to join that
team a few months ago I will be joining
him and Giancarlo Vera Nene also hosts
Varney newest yes
the monocultures yeah he was my manager
ferment for many years were you here
because he was here at GameSpot twice I
was here for the second time not the oh
not the first time the first time was
way way back in the early when he
invented Let's Plays yes did you talking
about this notion not so me develop
giancarlo invented let's play is the day
that he sat down in front of a green
screen and they shot him from the back
commenting on ducktales footage on the
NES you go back there's a video of him
commenting on ducktales footage from
like 2004 maybe
early 2000s at GameSpot before you know
video production technology and stuff
became you know as relatively affordable
and as it is today this site was like
did a lot of pioneering stuff and you
mentioned it earlier with our live
coverage Mary so that's been another fun
thing about working for the site as
being part of that but yeah I'm gonna go
work for you
congratulations Thanks it's just around
the way it's over on 3rd Street and
working with people that I really trust
and enjoy and working for a company that
I've admired I mean I don't like every
single Ubisoft game that they ever
published I can't say that now good
whoa I'm sorry we can have but man like
I was going down the list preparing for
these interviews and like yeah I like
that game like that can't play that game
love that game all right leave back back
off of that baby one of the things I
liked about working for GameSpot on the
editorial team was being able to cover a
diversity of games you be sauce catalog
he's diverse and I'm excited to get to
make videos about that stuff get back in
front of the camera a bunch more and
just kind of take on a new a new scene
although I am sad to leave you guys
because
GameSpot has been a transformative place
for me to say the least and working with
people like you and all the folks that
I've worked with over the years who are
some of whom are still here and some of
whom are on to new adventures has been
fantastic I mean you get to you get to
work at a place for a big chunk of years
and then you start like I don't know if
you guys do this you start comparing it
to like other times in your life that
have been write lengthy like I was in
college for four years yeah yeah I was
think about that just the other day
actually yeah yeah it's like range yeah
I've been doing this for I lived in the
Bay Area for over a decade you know I've
worked at Gamestop for almost a decade
like the the sort of scope of things and
their impact on your life you start to
reflect on that a lot more when you are
coming to the end of that time and so
I've been doing that a lot and it's been
wonderful to remember everything and I
could go on and on about being super
mushy but suffice to say thank you thank
you yeah and thank all of you it's
really meant a lot to me to do stuff for
you guys to be up here and to have all
your sport okay I do want to say another
thing before I change the subject and
yeah not be emotional yeah change the
subject to more of you Chris it has been
just a so wonderful for so many of us to
spend the years of your life here your
life's work is here and a lot of that is
captured on video
Danny O'Dwyer spent a lotta yesterday
going through a lot of footage he was
sick today as you know but I went
through a lot more footage and we put
together something suffice to say nine
years of work does not fit into three
minutes but we put something together to
remember all of the wonderful things
that you've done here and we'd like to
show it oh my goodness
a montage yeah let's roll that beautiful
bean footage today is Thursday January
8th and the show is gamespot news the
hosts first waters the setting the
GameSpot offices in San Francisco
California the producer Josh Shaw sets
the shot the microphone is affixed the
stories are memorized the sideburns are
mostly symmetrical all that remains is
to say that one little word
action
the mention of World War two and video
game in the same sentence may trigger
sudden onset apathy in many gamers but
one series has historically proven to be
a tonic for this crippling oddly
brothers-in-arms
yeah we lost one hey guys so Chris hi
Chris
then welcome weary internet user welcome
to the gun show the show that is
kick-starting its own floating
theocratic metropolis
we've decided to name it gun show Pia
and that's as far as we got let's just
kill it with guns lots of weird duck
guns VM 1216 goes bat bat bat bat then
bat some more hash tag bap tackler hash
tag bats on parade science murder on the
first tweet of Chris mist the gun show
sent to me the shotgun from spelunky
multiple players hey folks welcome to
multiple players
it's heard its first waters hey folks
welcome to the GameSpot studios -
welcome to today on the spot for Tuesday
September 22nd I'm your host Chris
waters and joining me over here in lark
Anderson there you go
okay I'll have to double in war zone and
Cliff Bleszinski what cliffy B yes
ladies and gentlemen of the Horde and
the Alliance alike welcome to warlords
of draenor worldwide cinematic premiere
it's a game that made me so so happy to
play video games and to love them and so
so happy for where video games are going
in the future
it was a lot of fun having you here hope
you had fun joining us and we'll see you
next week for on the spot
live from the game for us to do have a
great week